Este cuerpo es exhumado y un criminólogo
comenzó el examen
primero la ropa
un civil
pronto se hace evidente que el hombre
tiene lesiones en la zona genital
[Música]
le indica un colega que eche un vistazo
están claramente perturbados por lo que
ven
debido al Estado de putrefacción del
cuerpo se suspende el examen
Eso es todo es suficiente realmente
le oímos murmurar la palabra tortura
Pero no la repite ante la cámara está
prohibido dar conclusiones preliminares
solo los órganos judiciales sin
investigación pueden sacar conclusiones
Lo siento sin embargo los dirigentes
ucranianos no han dudado en afirmar que
algunas de las 460 personas enteradas
aquí fueron torturadas hasta la muerte
pero no tenemos ni idea de Cuántas la
mayoría de hecho murió bajo los
bombardeos cuando las fuerzas rusas
atacaron is you me marzo el primer día
de las exhumaciones se vio al personal
de una funeraria siendo interrogado por
la policía los días más tarde nos
reunimos con vital y el director de la
empresa que nos explicó que las personas
habían sido enterradas en tumbas poco
profundas en patios y Jardines de la
ciudad los rusos pidieron a su empresa
que los trasladaron fue necesario volver
a enterrarlos a todos como puedo
describirselo es la guerra había
constantes bombardeos Así que la gente
acababa de ser enterrada allí donde
había muerto pero a veces los rusos le
pedían a vital y que enterrar a cuerpos
que Aparentemente no habían muerto en el
bombardeo;
nos traían los cuerpos con las manos
atadas a la espalda
eso sugiere que ataron a la persona y la
torturaron Esa es mi opinión aunque no
puedo probarlo
los entierradores dijeron a la policía
que volvieron a sepultar al menos a 60
personas en tres lugares diferentes pero
que no los re enteraron a todos